cuando tú estudias química con
frecuencia vez reacciones de hecho
siempre estás viendo reacciones por
ejemplo si tienes hidrógeno gaseoso
déjame ponerlo aquí h2 en estado gaseoso
ok la cual es una molécula de atómica
porque el hidrógeno se enlace asimismo
en el estado gaseoso ya esto le
aumentamos am y de reponerlo así a esto
le voy a aumentar a yodo pero también en
estado gaseoso más y
2 ok en estado gaseoso si te das cuenta
es que es muy fácil decirlo o ya sabes
si ponemos a ellos van a reaccionar y
formar el siguiente producto es decir si
tenemos un molde de hidrógeno más un
molde yodo bueno pues esto nos va a dar
dos moles ok de yoduro de hidrógeno de
yoduro de hidrógeno ok entonces déjame
puedes decir h y ok hasta ahorita parece
ser todo simple y claro y lo hace
parecer como si sucediera sin ninguna
confusión pero sabemos que en la
realidad no es así y también sabemos que
no sucede de manera instantánea no es
como si tomas algunos hidrógenos y los
pones con algunos yodo y mágicamente se
convierten en yoduro de hidrógeno existe
un proceso que ocurre en el estado
gaseoso donde las partículas están
rebotando y de alguna manera deben
rebotar unas con otras
ver los enlaces que las mantenían unidas
para formar nuevos enlaces y justo eso
es lo que vamos a estudiar ahora y por
cierto el estudio de cómo progresan las
reacciones y las velocidades de reacción
se le conoce como cinética y lo voy a
poner aquí sí
y acá y bueno tal vez me vayas a decir
que esta es una palabra rara pero
probablemente te sea familiar porque ya
hemos hablado de energía cinética
cinética es el estudio de las
velocidades de la reacción cuán rápido
sucede y cómo suceden pero bueno es hora
de regresar al ejemplo entonces vamos a
imaginar de alguna forma intuitiva que
el hidrógeno y el yodo pueden combinarse
así que pensemos cómo se verá el
hidrógeno hoy para eso
déjame tomar mi tabla periódica déjame
subir un poco la pantalla porque justo
por aquí tengo a mi tabla periódica
déjame subir un poco más la pantalla
para que veas y te des cuenta de lo
siguiente en este lugar justo por aquí
tengo al hidrógeno
vamos a tomar este color y fíjate que
aquí tengo al hidrógeno y el hidrógeno
si te das cuenta tiene un electrón de
valencia entonces si una molécula tiene
dos átomos de hidrógeno
van a compartir los electrones por otra
parte el yodo y dejen utilizar el mismo
color para que veas el yodo el yodo está
justo por aquí el yodo tiene 7
electrones de valencia y eso nos va a
ayudar para que sigamos con nuestro
ejemplo porque si regresamos justo por
aquí entonces vamos a ponerlo si yo me
fijo en el hidrógeno pues más o menos se
vería algo así
este hidrógeno de aquí ok tiene un
electrón justo aquí déjame poner este
con su electrón de valencia mientras que
aquí tenemos h 2 aquí tenemos otro
hidrógeno este de aquí el cual tiene por
acá su electrón de valencia y entonces
se forma un enlace y los comparten se
forma un enlace el cual nos ayuda a que
este hidrógeno pueda hacer que tiene
este electrón y se sienta completo
mientras que este hidrógeno puede hacer
como que tiene a este electrón y
entonces serán felices
ambos sienten que han completado su capa
1 s ahora lo mismo sucede con los yo 2
antes que me ponemos aquí tengo un yodo
por aquí ok
tengo otro yodo por aquí ok y bueno
tienen 7 electrones de valencia así que
vamos a poner los 12 a ok 3 4 5 6 1 2 3
4 5 ó 6 y aquí está su séptimo electrón
de valencia son halógenos y bueno tú ya
sabes que los halógenos son del grupo 17
entonces tienen 7 electrones ahora si
creamos un enlace entre ellos si creamos
un enlace entre ellos
bueno pues date cuenta que si este átomo
puede suponer que tiene este electrón
entonces estará feliz pues ya tendría 8
electrones de valencia y si este átomo
puede suponer que le pertenece este otro
dentro lo mismo entonces tenemos este
enlace aquí ok y por eso el hidrógeno es
un gas molecular y atómico y el yodo
también ahora bien cuando están en
estado gaseoso tienes un montón de estas
cosas muy viéndose y chocando entre sí
el hidrógeno se vería más o menos así
tengo a algo más o menos así porque
tengo dos pequeñas moléculas ok estas
son mis dos esferas atómicas y están
enlazadas juntas porque tienen
electrones entre ellas los electrones
que están compartiendo y eso es lo que
las mantiene enlazadas y el yodo el yodo
se puede ver más o menos así es una
molécula mucho más grande am se ve más o
menos así ok
este me gusta como el yodo ok tenemos
una molécula más grande y también están
compartiendo algunos electrones en su
enlace covalente por lo tanto los voy a
pintar así y después todo es cuestión de
probabilística ahora bien para que estas
dos moléculas se conviertan en esto
una manera estos enlaces deben de
romperse y deben formar nuevos enlaces y
lo que tenga que sucederle a estas
moléculas y de hecho hay toneladas de
estas moléculas así que déjame
atraparlas justo con esto y voy a pegar
varias de ellas o keitai en atrapar está
ok y pegar ok esto está aquí vamos a
poner otra por acá y es más déjame bajar
un poco la pantalla bajemos un poco la
pantalla para que sigamos este
procedimiento y ahora me voy a tomar una
de yodo y otra más de yodo la voy a
atrapar algo más o menos así ok la voy a
copiar y la voy a pegar de lujo ahora
están un montón de estas moléculas
tenemos un puñado de moléculas de
hidrógeno y algunas de estas moléculas
de yodo a su alrededor bien ahora lo que
sucede para que tengamos los yo duros de
hidrógeno es que estas moléculas de
alguna forma tienen que colisionar es
decir esta molécula se va a acercar a
esta y de una cierta manera va a tener
que colisionar
manera exacta y esto me agrada cómo está
quedando digamos que esta molécula se
está moviendo algo así ok y entonces
solamente estoy arrastrando y soltando
se está moviendo y ahora choca con la
molécula de hidrógeno ahora sí justo
choca con la suficiente energía de
repente digamos que está en este punto y
es hora de dibujar entonces los
electrones dirán hey sabes estamos bien
siendo compartidos de esta forma estamos
en una configuración estable mira
estamos llenando esta primera capa pero
observa éste yodo está tan cerca y me
atrae tanto ellos son mucho más electro
negativos y me atraen más que el
hidrógeno y entonces ellos se verán
atraídos justo aquí no saben si están
más atraídos a quedarse justo aquí entre
los hidrógenos o aquí entre éstos yo dos
por eso entran en un estado de alta
energía y lo mismo para estos chicos
dicen ay no sería mejor a no tenemos que
estar aquí
aquí este es mi átomo pero si bien en
estos dos entonces dejó molécula y como
tenemos que ser 8 electrones de valencia
entonces estos dos me atraen y lo mismo
sucede aquí y esta situación que les
cuento justo aquí es la situación cuando
ocurre la colisión
justo cuando ocurre la colisión es el
estado de alta energía o el estado de
transición de la reacción y este estado
es llamado complejo activado y déjame
ponerlo con este color este estado de
aquí se le conoce como complejo complejo
ok activa activa
complejo activado y ya sabes trate de
hacerlo visualmente pero también podrías
pensar lo justo así el hidrógeno el
hidrógeno tiene un enlace covalente y
aquí tenemos al hidrógeno ok
aquí está su enlace covalente ok y por
otra parte tenemos al yodo y el yodo
también tiene su enlace covalente el
yodo o que está por aquí y también tiene
su enlace covalente ahora como estas
moléculas están muy cerca de repente
estos chicos también forman otro enlace
forman otro enlace por aquí ok y este
también forma otro enlace por aquí ok y
ojo se empieza a formar este otro enlace
porque empieza a haber una pequeña
atracción de este lado y de este lado
también entonces esta es otra manera de
dibujar el complejo activado pero este
es un estado de alta energía porque para
el electrón la forma de verlo es yendo
de este enlace
este enlace de este enlace a este enlace
y para eso necesitan entrar en un estado
de alta energía el cual es menos estable
que el estado anterior y bueno lo logran
si hay suficiente energía disponible
puedes llegar aquí de estos átomos
separados a este estado y es más
permíteme dibujarlos separados
primero teníamos el hidrógeno por aquí
ok
1 2 3 4 que aquí tengo el hidrógeno más
y bueno también tenemos el yodo ok con
su enlace covalente ok y para llegar de
este estado de este estado a este estado
entonces estamos pasando a un estado de
alta energía y bueno se puede alcanzar
este estado de alta energía si hay
suficiente energía para la colección y
tienen suficiente energía cinética donde
chocan con la correcta orientación
entonces desde este complejo activado o
este estado de alta energía pasan a un
estado de menor energía qué
el yoduro de hidrógeno este estado de
menor energía es el yoduro de hidrógeno
y lo voy a poner justo así y tengo aquí
mis dos yo dos y ahora voy a poner acá a
mis dos hidrógenos ok y ahora voy a
hacer el enlace entre ellos y de hecho
este estado es de menor energía que este
estado este estado tiene menor energía
que este otro estado pero para pasar a
este estado al yoduro de hidrógeno lo
que necesitamos es pasar por un estado
de alta energía y todo esto lo puedo
representar con un gráfico de energía
así que déjenme bajar un poco más esta
pantalla para trabajar un gráfico por
aquí y este gráfico lo voy a hacer más o
menos así voy a decir que en el eje x
tengo un justo por aquí en mi eje x voy
a tener el progreso de la reacción ok
vamos a ponerlo aquí tengo el progreso
pero ingreso de la reacción y bueno por
ahora no sabemos cuál del 2 mente
progresa pero puedas verlo como tiempo
dentro de una cierta dimensión y bueno
digamos que el otro eje este eje de aquí
ok
este va a ser energía potencial este de
aquí me va a representar la energía
potencial energía potencial de lujo y
bueno inicialmente estamos en este
estado de aquí en este estado de aquí el
cual bueno nosotros sabemos que es h 2 +
y 2 h 2 + y ok 2 este es mi estado
inicial y un estado de menor energía lo
encontraremos justo aquí este es mi
estado con menor energía y es cuando se
produce el yoduro de hidrógeno
este es el estado de menor energía es
decir el estado final y es dos veces h y
de lujo pero para llegar aquí tenemos
que llegar hasta esta energía de
activación y bueno los electrones deben
de tener algo de energía para que por lo
menos puedan encontrar qué hacer con sus
vidas
ahora bien entonces deben de aportar
energía al sistema no siempre debes de
agregarla pero si esto no sucede
espontáneamente tú deberás aportar
energía al sistema ok para lograr este
estado activado de acuerdo justo así y
entonces estamos justo aquí en este
estado de activación ok ahora la
diferencia entre la energía que teníamos
cuando sólo teníamos moléculas de
hidrógeno y de yodo y la energía que
tenemos que alcanzar para lograr este
estado de activación am y déjame ponerlo
con este color la distancia que hay de
aquí acá
y esta distancia se le conoce como la
energía de activación
esta es la energía ok de activación a
activación
ok la energía de activación que por
cierto a veces se escribe como
energía de activación
y más adelante tal vez trabajemos
reacciones en las que podamos medir la
energía de activación pero lo importante
es entender conceptualmente lo que
sucede si podemos de alguna manera
aportar suficiente energía al sistema
entonces la reacción sucederán las
moléculas van a condicionar con
suficiente energía y los enlaces se
romperán y se reformarán y bueno también
lo importante es que veas que esto no
sucede de una manera espontánea desde
aquí y hasta acá y bueno no voy a
profundizar en catálisis ahora pero
probablemente hayas escuchado la palabra
catálisis o que algo es catalizado y hay
algunos otros agentes otros factores que
afectan a esta reacción y es más déjame
bajar un poco la pantalla para
explicarte un poco a qué me refiero por
ejemplo si nosotros empezamos con am h 2
h 2 + y 2 ok y después obtenemos dos
veces yoduro de hidrógeno ok ya lo tengo
justo aquí bueno pues puedes tener
catálisis y si tienes catálisis le
agregamos una sed y aquí está se se
conserva y bueno no sé cuál sería un
buen catalizador para esta reacción y
como un catalizador puede operar pero
puedo hacerlo en muchas formas distintas
por eso no quiero incluirlo en este
vídeo pero un catalizador es algo que no
cambia no es consumido en la reacción
aquí está el catalizador lo tenemos
justo antes de la reacción y date cuenta
que el catalizador sigue estando después
de la reacción pero lo que hace es
lograr que la reacción suceda más rápido
o bajando la cantidad de energía
necesaria para que ocurra la reacción
que al final es casi lo mismo así que si
entonces yo subo un poco la pantalla y
nos fijamos ahora en esto que teníamos
anteriormente si tienes un catalizador
en todo
y la energía de activación esta energía
de activación será menor lo que hace es
permitir la existencia de otros estados
de transición que requieren menos
energía potencial entonces la reacción
requiere menos calor o menos
concentración de moléculas chocando unas
con otras en la dirección correcta para
pasar de este estado a este otro estado
con la catálisis entonces se requiere
menor energía dada la forma en que
entendemos como sucede la cinética
química de estas moléculas interactuando
unas con otras ahora te pregunto cuáles
piensas que serán las cosas de las que
depende que la reacción suceda o no y
bueno para hablar de ellas déjenme bajar
un poco la pantalla cuáles son las cosas
ok de las que depende que la reacción
suceda o no bueno pues la primera es que
ya sabemos que la catálisis positiva y
déjame ponerlo así la capta
this is ok y lleva acento en esta
positiva positiva nos ayuda a que se
reduzca la energía de activación y
también existe algo llamado catálisis
negativa que retarda la reacción pero si
tenemos catálisis positiva obviamente
reducirá la energía de activación y hará
que la reacción ante jaime poner así la
reacción sea más rápido reacción
reacción
una rápida rápida ok
más molécula chocarán con otras en
condiciones de superar esta cima esta
cima que teníamos acá arriba ok
porque la cima será menor cuando tienes
un catalizador bien que otro podrá
afectar a lo que nosotros queremos bueno
pues si aumenta la concentración cierto
concentración con tracción ok si
aumentas la concentración
bueno pues va a haber más moléculas aquí
las cuales van de chocando a las unas
con las otras aquí tenemos un montón de
moléculas y entonces tienes más
moléculas para chocar entre sí no es así
es sólo probable todo aquí todo en esto
es probabilístico cuando la gente
escribe las ecuaciones químicas justo
estás aquí bueno todo parece simple ya
no y claro y la reacción ocurre pero no
en el mundo real solo tienes cosas
rebotando las unas con las otras y
cuando veamos vídeos de biología será
una charla fascinante porque cada
proceso biológico es en realidad un
proceso químico y es justamente el
producto de estas cosas rebotando las
unas con las otras y puedes imaginar que
cuanto mayor sea tu concentración ok
entre más concentración tengas bueno
tenemos más concentración de lo que
queremos que choquen entre sí am aquí
tengo la otra molécula y entonces es más
probable que vayamos a tener los choques
perfectos y la cantidad de energía
cinética adecuada para que suceda la
reacción y es más esto me da pie hacer
otra nota aquí dejamos subir un poco la
pantalla porque si nosotros nos fijamos
aquí y decimos esta reacción podría
decir ok tenemos algo de veamos
tengo este nivel de energía como puede
llegar hasta aquí como será posible que
pase la reacción bien recuerda en un gas
la energía cinética de todas las
moléculas no es uniforme algunas
moléculas tendrán mucha energía cinética
otras tendrán poca
y bueno la temperatura nos indica
justamente el promedio entonces siempre
es probable que las dos moléculas con
alta energía cinética choquen entre sí
perfectamente sobrepasando este nivel
porque tienen suficiente energía
cinética para llegar al estado de
activación y pueden pasar a esta energía
de activación y después pasa al estado
de menor energía que es el yoduro de
hidrógeno esto sucede a cualquier
temperatura pero obviamente se aumenta
esa temperatura y dejará bajar hasta la
pantalla porque esa es otra si
aumentamos la temperatura
entonces am y déjenme ponerlo con este
color si aumentamos la temperatura
en p
tura aumenta okay pues entonces la
reacción va a aumentar la presión va a
aumentar y de igual manera aquí a la
reacción va a aumentar reacción va a
aumentar ok de lujo la temperatura es
probablemente el agente con mayor
capacidad para acelerar la reacción de
todas estas cosas a mayor temperatura
mayor reacción y si quieres pensar en
moléculas si tú tienes moléculas en las
que sus enlaces originales son débiles
es mucho más probable que interactúen
dejamos subir a través un poco la
pantalla fíjate bien existen otras cosas
sobre las cuales hablar la forma de la
molécula puedan disponibles están
ciertos átomos para interactuar con
otros eso se vuelve más importante
cuando empezamos con biología pero bueno
por último por último tenemos a mí
déjame bajar un poco más la pantalla por
último y probablemente ya te diste
cuenta es el área de contacto y lo voy a
poner así
área se aumenta el área entonces también
la reacción aumenta la reacción aumenta
ok y me vas a decir es que estamos
hablando de la interacción gas con gas
lo cual por definición tiene mucha área
de contacto pero si la superficie de
contacto aumenta entonces la reacción
también aumenta la velocidad de reacción
y qué piensas de esto bien piensa en la
siguiente reacción si nosotros tenemos a
lo duro de sodio y eso ya lo hemos hecho
muchas veces si nosotros tenemos lo duro
de sodio y lo voy a poner a sólido ok ya
esto le sumó agua líquida ok
h2o en forma líquida bueno pues esto me
da este resultado bueno pues podemos
pensar en ello en diferentes formas pero
nosotros imaginaremos iones de sodio ok
lo voy a poner así iones de sodio acuoso
ok
a uniones de cloruro ok cloruro neones
de cloruro también en estado acuoso ok
este es un camión y una unión acuoso es
decir están disueltos y como ocurre esto
bueno si tienes un gran cubo de hielo
déjame bajar un poco más la pantalla
para explicarte o no no perdón no es
hielo es sal si nosotros hacemos aquí un
cubo este va a ser mi cubo de sal
ok tenemos un cubo de sal y le ponemos
agua
ok tenemos un buen de agua bueno pues
date cuenta que el área de contacto va a
ser esta parte de aquí esta parte de
aquí va a representar mi área de
contacto
hay muchos átomos de sodio y cloruro
aquí adentro y bueno lentamente se va a
disolver la sal y lentamente se podrá
establecer enlaces polares estos por
cierto son enlaces por lo tipo lo con
los diferentes iones de sodio o cloruro
pero si te pides esos mismos cubos
y vamos a moler los si dividimos esos
mismos cubos en cubos o en pedazos más
pequeños
voy a tener aquí a mis pedazos de sal ok
y a éstos los disuelvo también en agua
ok vamos a poner el agua justo por aquí
ok entonces date cuenta que la
superficie de contacto sobre las que las
moléculas de agua puede interactuar está
aumentando realmente puede interactuar
con más cloruro de sodio
la reacción entonces ocurrirá más rápido
entonces si aumentas el área de contacto
va a aumentar la velocidad de la
reacción si tratas de hacerlo por
ejemplo con dos fluidos lo que puedes
hacer es dispensar un fluido dentro del
otro produciendo pequeñas gotas
incrementando el área de contacto de
todas maneras esto es una introducción a
la cinética y es más déjenme subir un
poco más de pantalla porque todo esto
espero que te dé una idea de que estas
reacciones y no quiero que piense sobre
la química de esta forma como puras
ecuaciones no pienses
solo son fórmulas que debo de recordar
si no que pienses que son golpes y
moretones entre átomos que suceden
probabilísticamente y de manera
desordenada y debemos pensar sobre qué
agentes harán más probables los choques
perfectos para que las reacciones
ocurran